Hi.
Hi, Drew Barrymore.
Hello Eddie Murphy.
I'm so happy to see you too.
Happy to see you too.
I mean 1982.
You were just a little baby when I met you.
And there we were.
Just a little baby.
And look at you and I.
You're just a baby (laughs).
I'm kind of young too.
I think I'm like 19 or 20 then.
I remember Tim Kazurinsky,
you kind of liked, you guys were buddies
that we became buddies with him.
I did, I gravitated towards him.
He was so nice to me.
You guys were cute.
Do you remember doing the T sketch?
You were Mr. T looking for his boy E.
And I don't know if you remember this
but Steven Spielberg was there.
He was very protective of me at that time.
I was so lucky.
You know what's so strange
about the whole "SNL" experience it was so long ago.
And sometimes there'll be like a sketch on
and I won't even remember the sketch,
I'll be watching it going,
what is this sketch and how, what happens next?
It's like so much it's so long ago
in so many sketches in between that
and so much stuff.
A lot of times I don't remember it.
I don't remember that Mr. T sketch.
I just remember everything from that show very vividly
but I too have like, you know, surrealistic.
I can imagine you're a little baby when you started.
I was reading about how that you lean
into being a spiritual person and being centered
and that you said maybe you avoided some
of the pitfalls that were so easy
at your disposal, if you will, because of spirituality.
Is that true?
Yeah, I'm very grounded spiritually.
And not so much, you know, any religion
just a connection with God.
Being a young person in this business
and it's like you got to navigate through a mine field.
There's so many ways you could just destroy yourself.
A lot of the people that I've seen that destroy themselves,
a lot of my contemporaries, a bunch of my contemporaries
people like Michael and Prince and Whitney and people
that came on the scene around the same age that I am,
they kind of there was this self destructive thing
that they had.
That's my biggest blessing,
that I got started really early.
I knew what I wanted to do really, really young.
And then I loved myself, I never hated myself.
I never beat up on myself.
I've always been my biggest fan (laughs).
I love that you deserve to be
'cause we're all there with you.
What would you say to someone who like
does struggle with like call it self Love.
I'm asking for myself 'cause I love and respect myself,
but I fall off the wagon with total self-flagellation
and like, being too hard
and not meeting my own expectations.
Do you have any advice for me?
It's a inward search.
And it's personal and it's just between you and you
and the outside stuff you have to learn
to not like,
I don't even let anything that's not constructive.,
I don't let anything negative in.
You have to train yourself to turn away from it.
When negative stuff comes in stuff, that's not constructive,
you have to turn from like.
You're here and then you're blessed.
You're here and you're blessed, you're already won.
So the negative energy, there's no time for that.
You won already.
You know what you should do every morning?
What?
You should do a victory dance.
You should wake up every morning
and do a Drew Barrymore victory dance.
I won.
(both laugh)
You won mama?
I feel like the world's biggest winner right now
to hear such salient advice from someone I have respected
so much my whole life.
And in 1982, when we did "Saturday night Live" together,
then you know you had done 48 hours
trading places, "Beverly Hills Cop" by the way-
And you were just delirious right in the middle of that.
The red leather suit is right in the middle of that stuff.
What exact point was "RAW" to that?
Right after "Coming to America".
Oh yeah, so that's '87.
I could tell, 'cause I have a perm.
My hair is that hair (laughs).
You had such a succession of these epic films,
you're so young.
Do you ever come down from those periods
of time where you have hit after hit
after hit and you're working, working, working?
I'll tell you what happened to me.
I had it all the way together for years and years and years.
And then what happened with movies is they started offering
you so much money to do stuff that I wound up doing all
you know what that's like.
You just still be like, hey you want to give me
that much money to do that (beep)?
(Drew laughs)
Bunch of movies like that and it's forever.
Way after the (beep) money is spent that movie is like still
playing on a movie channel.
So it's like, so I got to
where I stopped having fun making movies.
I had to take a time like about in 2011
I think it was, I'd stopped for like eight years.
I just stopped making movies.
And that's where I had really, really quiet time
and got re-centered where, you know, if I'm going to
be doing something, I want to be doing it because I want
to do it and all that.
And I got it all back together that way.
That is the perfect answer to that question.
And the reason I asked is because, you know
since that 1982 time, and I had even been working
before that and so had you, but we're still here.
We're still going.
It's 30, 40 years later, 40 years later-
That's why I said you should do the victory dance.
How about this?
We're in the business Drew where people come and go,
where people come and go every five years.
It's a brand new bunch of new faces.
And it's a brand new,
and anybody that's in this business
for as long as you've been in this business,
as long as I have been in this business, I think, you know
that means that we're not stinky.
(both laugh)
It has has been firmly established that we are not stinky.
(bright music)